one or two missing but okay
um
nice too nice to know that everybody is
watching us on youtube hope you have a
nice time
but we'll get started
who's that just walk through the door
two minutes confirmation of the minister
november
um i'll just
run through the pages
page three
page four
page five
day six page seven
sorry
what yes
what what
the meeting
sean is looking at
at the moment
grant has got two 250 items on his books
um they're gonna have to sit and go
through it a lot of it
i actually went out with grant for half
a day
uh two winters ago
which was very successful actually um
and we're gonna i'm gonna
do it again with him and and go wider
maybe into one or two of his
areas to my area and uh and because with
grant found it much easier that there
was two
we got into a place that
he wouldn't have
sent to going in on his own
and so yeah
but yeah i've done that
um
john harrington is looking into it again
at the moment because of the amount that
is of things that he's got on so we'll
just take it from there
all right
about nikki can you go with that
what about nikki that's this side
no no i've been nominated
i think it's very similar to what grant
has done
yeah i don't thought we're taking on a
temporary person or anything
um
well if we if we did that with then we'd
have to go to
steam
and
ken
and find out if we've got some money to
do it but then again for me because it's
planning is earning the most money
i think they should be able to do it
anyway but
uh yeah
yeah actually um
obviously when you take on additional
resources that slows up the work the
rest of the team in the meantime
that tends to be the main issue and
obviously at the moment anyway it's very
challenging uh to recruit um just across
the board so
so it's not it's not something sean has
come to me and said can we do as yet no
it won't be just yet
so you're prioritizing particular cases
and
have you got an end date in mind when it
could be cleared i mean
what sort of no
no idea at all
that's the honest answer i've got to
take here we've got one so we haven't
okay
but i i keep talking i keep having
meetings with sean and ellen anyway
and we
look at all the aspects of the planet
so in fact i'm i'm seeing them beginning
all right yeah i mean basically a signal
to people that they can
basically lack of enforcement gives a
signal to people that they can
get away with things here but
you should always remember one thing
yeah we don't have to do it
no no it's not a statutory thing for us
we don't need we don't have to do it if
we don't want to
so but we do
don't wait
yes we do we like so we don't have to
it's discussion
it's got the accuracy
anyway
uh okay
a proposal
yes um
i'm quite sure i might be mistaken but i
think i attended this your last scrutiny
meeting and there is
uh if it could be confirmed and myself
added as i came to it i find your
meetings fascinating
there's no need to tell life
kirsty yes
how could we forget claire sorry
well i think councillor laws might have
been there because we tend to travel in
town then
he was yeah yeah you're dead right and
capture a lot is not on there well i
miss that
[Music]
simon shirley
okay all those in favor
keep going
six
six six four yeah
uh abstention
one abstention
yeah okay
right such uh anything that i mean in
the past people have sort of raised
things about the minutes in terms of
what's happened so
when you know if we're not supposed to
do it
i'm just trying to get clear can one
raise these things when you go through
the minutes like that or
well you could have done it when i've
finished yeah okay i apologize that's
when i would have prepared you to do it
finished right thank you all right
simon i think the word is matters of
rising isn't it chad that's right
that's that's the title
action list
which is on page 10
9 and 10.
it's actually
131 grand maintenance service um that
action is still ongoing
133 qbi 2 breakdown
yes
on the new discovery app
you've got that yeah that's completely
133 qbr2 information from dc c recovery
group
sean came to speak to phil collins
you can't answer this
okay just just remember i think i should
be phil adams from college
that's still ongoing right next page
um yeah yes yes sorry um what are we
like
now six weeks ago bottom i said when are
we likely to get an answer because it's
nearly six weeks
that's when
[Music]
and
do you want the answer sent out an email
i think it'll be helpful
yeah instead of having to wait yeah
and do that
okay
qbr2 further response required from
community projects
complete
[Music]
well
[Music]
of interest you will understand about
the declarations of interest anyway
agent match has brought forward the
permission of the chair i've got no
urgent matters
i don't know something brings between
part one and two
no part two
item eight review of the qbr pages 11 to
80. okay and we have got
chris gonna do this for
yeah
good morning
let's start we're taking this wet
tournament
to
the council published a new plan
um
in the autumn i wanted to make sure our
performance reporting
was seamlessly all the way through from
the strap plan to the business plans to
the ppr this committee to the public to
make sure it was getting intentionally
aligned it was clear
so instead of a task group in this
committee
i think a lot of changes to the qbr
formats i've done from somewhere here
richard aligned the actions from the
strat plan to the qbr
we went to landscape layouts
we started paying putting the notes on
performance against learning measures
and actions
completely number of the financial pages
so more information
and actually speed consumption questions
magnitude of the variance
and we just wanted to make it easier to
understand
[Music]
fundamental things we did fantastic
finish
where we are now
[Music]
we didn't have our six which analysis
was in the qgr4 we've got the new qp
artist from the thief cycles one on two
so you see two key cards in the new
formats
and worried to make sure we have a
review so i've actually got it right
um so it's an improvement on the lqpr
just in fact you guys are what you need
it's easy to understand and analyze and
it's the further improvements needed
for me is that um new format is it's
just in a word template so it's really
easy to change
so it's only nothing says anymore we can
attach it and amend it quite easily
um i sent our survey an amendment to
members got 40 responses back the next
class let's just look at those responses
so question one was just on the layout
it was so easy to read and scrutinize
and get a hundred percent of people
responded saying yes they agreed i
strongly agreed to that so it's from
response
second was like actions from the strat
plan
to the tbr reporting again
19th century responsive agreed i
strongly agreed that we actually got
that right as well
the question is about which information
be easy to understand
again 100 of respondents agreed i
strongly agree
the next one was about the actual
investments including equity investments
[Music]
and then question five
um
is about performance indicators
um
make it easy to read
in the current year
and we have sentimental responses that
we've strongly agreed but nobody
disagreed with that one
so i have just a summary table down
below a chart just showing
how do you know they all came down to
nuclear we are building was 5.1 out of
10
new ones 8.1 out of 10 so
you can kind of say well it's not
perfect but it's been a big improvement
and finally there
any comments we have six comments back
on the final question
first of all about actions being taken
to blue performance we have more details
my own view on that one is that the qpr
kind of provides you with the facts and
actually this committee has been
asking those questions so the questions
and answers can be managed if you need
to so i'm kind of happy that the gives
you information and you answer questions
um
it's almost like more year-on-year
figures i've actually taken that out
into a separate change report so i think
that one's been dealt with
the third one
sadly
[Music]
next two
things okay i think the sixth comment
probably the questions wrong one because
the episode which is it's been a really
good facelift it's been a big
improvement
um
as we go forward
and changes to make it attached and then
you go forward
and then in the comment box i think this
was back to uh i think it's one of these
dates in august
um
yesterday we actually took out into
properties
indicators into the year analysis
because it was almost kind of watching
zero
um
and wasn't moving
suggestions back in august
so in terms of today
that's what's happening right there's a
different purpose
and technology isn't even
any changes today improvements
and obviously he's lost as well
what do we do in the future we either
change it as and when it really rises
is a change
okay and then i'm going to review the
qbl
oh she's looking again a few years time
like i said nothing's set in stone we
need to change the format
and we've made a big change this year
that can be twitched going forward if it
needs to be improved
we're going to hand over to the chair
and say what do we do today
chris anybody got any questions
okay we'll go shirley first then just
intrigued how many
do you know how many people you would
buy who were us
and how many were other counselors
[Music]
see we're not embarrassed can we
actually just put our hands up who here
replied
so it gives us an idea one two three
four
so five were marking our own homework
thank you right
now i'm just interested to know
how
it would be a miracle if we got 36
responses
and it would and
well if we got 36 responses in anything
it would be a miracle so so yeah i mean
but
me personally i think we've done a done
good job with this and i think it
will
work really well
um
what do you want to say yeah it's a good
response you know it's just a bit
intrigued about you know this one on
performance indicators more deep comment
about more detail and actions required
interesting to know what
sort of detail people wanted really but
i don't know who asked the question i
suppose
the thing is with this new qbi that it's
an ongoing thing
you know if we find
later on
in the next qbr that what we could do
with changing something then we should
do it you know it's not
the thing that we we need to look at
this now and say that's it we can't do
anything else to it
i mean this this committee is to look at
scrutinize what goes on and entourage
and
you know
propose
improvements if necessary so yeah
i mean we're looking we look at the
image um
the one the one
recommendations
yeah
um bbo 64 empty properties me personally
i think we should move that to
qbr4
at the end of the year
and anybody else
think of them
well i i would agree with that yeah
do we do we all agree with that
sure vance paul agreed
before
okay chuck can i just make a comment
yeah come on
i think
i think the results and survey without
crying from our own nest but
one of the classical first group members
i think we would have been very
disappointed had those had those results
not being roughly in that play but it
was it was pretty obvious that what we
were producing was easier to follow and
really i mean that that wasn't that
wasn't a marginal sort of thing
um
although you say it's always been like
that it has ever been thus the the lack
of interest
in it
actually is the more telling thing
especially when you discount the number
here who were just doing it for though
but actually what people from here said
didn't count because i said they're
marking their own homework uh we aren't
the target audience in
other people
should we be
looking at
and the qbr is
if people think it's something to do
with the budget
and
actually as we know
basis
of
saying how this our council
is performing
and it is the only measurement
authoritative measurement we have to say
whether something is a performing or not
and running from that
people start if they get into this or
they're prepared to
get into it they start to understand
understand scope
scale
uh limitations
um
all the things which we see that crop up
in our various discussions in full
council
where people some of our members perhaps
their vision strays little beyond their
own ward area and
this is statutory work on us
legally we are required to do this uh
looking at the whole
and exactly i wonder whether we should
have a discussion as to whether there
are
things that we could do
to
interest
a wider um
number of counselors to to to to either
learn about it or or actually discover
what it really does
uh and how useful it is
we've gone
to considerable lengths to make it more
readable
and also to to be um
more
straightforward
easier easier
easier to read um it worries me that
more counsellors don't have an interest
in actually how their council is
performing but but
some
years have been like this
yes but david
you are you are just by saying that you
are just perpetuating the unsatisfactory
situation you never give up
disappointing actually so
and
you know um
wait okay see
um yeah kind of hear what members say
one one of the things we think we had in
place in the past uh was that the chair
of the committee would prepare an annual
report to full council
um on the performance through each of
the the qbr so uh reported at the end of
the year the performance that's been
attributable through this reporting
mechanism so that all members of our
council are not aware of the kind of
final output obviously all members
council have access to the reports and
can
see them as
and when necessary so it's it's kind of
one piece of the overall governance
framework so
um there's things around the account so
i'll see uh the ordered committee review
the accounts uh we've got the the
strategic plan which obviously reported
to full council reported through
leadership and except we're saying this
is probably the the one document and the
one reported structure that kind of
pulls uh a lot of that a lot of
performance information together so
having a report from the committee from
the committee chair to full council
might help to develop a wider
understanding if that's something that
the committee wish to consider
what's good and what's not so good
what needs to be looked at but
it's all right doing these reports but
to be quite honest
there is enough information goes out to
all councillors
and obviously you know the big thing is
trying to make them to
get them to read it that is the big
thing i mean whether you put a report
out every week every month every every
six months or whatever it doesn't mean
to say you're going to read it
because it's a short report for the
stadium
a couple of clicks on a keyboard
perhaps
every time the qbr is produced
then actually it is sent specifically to
all counselors
not just
available to them if they go look for it
on the site but actually every quarter
to all councillors
we send the qbr
um
some extra may open it some may open it
and at least read the the the summary at
the beginning which may perhaps let
their appetite lead them into it but at
the moment so i think we should we
should go on to to um
sort of push rather than pull um so
we should put it into their their
inboxes um
as a specific email entry that would
cause no extra work sure that's right um
i would imagine is easily done
i'm looking for a
nodding head somewhere um
so i'm not wanting to create any extra
work but
um it actually then at least puts it
there for them rather than them
fine
just waiting
all right
now what is
it needs to stand alone we can we can do
that we can we can send it out if you
know i mean kesley sends that to us so
all she has to do is if or
um we used to do that we used to send it
to everybody when we asked the questions
but because we got the uh qpr a little
bit um
ready earlier we then just sent out the
agenda so actually sending it out to all
counselors asking for questions
in advance as we've done before
is it's not a it's not a problem it's
something that we can do and as you said
it's a separate email that they can
click on
about reporting to full council to
committees
we regularly report to cnr any
recommendations or or
information that you
think those that committee
needs to be aware of we regularly do a
report
to from this committee or from david but
from this committee to cnr anyway so
there is that mechanism
so i don't think we you know used to
kind of not forget that
um
and i think actually i i don't think we
should take away
the role of this committee because
actually it is your role
you're doing well and i think i think if
you weren't that's when other counselors
might be picking it up but because you
are challenging you are doing reports to
cr when it's needed actually
that's a benefit and a bonus to this
committee i think i think you're doing
what what what we should be doing
don't you take that away from yourselves
yeah yeah entirely john i'm just keen
that we use this as a tool
to to try to
widen councillor's interests in actually
the core roles of
the council and actually the core
cogs that make it that make it work of
which the performance aspect this is
this is the one to read this is where
you go for it
um what we're trying to do simon is get
more people to look at it
that's all we i mean if we can't keep
pushing it and pushing it towards right
full council because if we do that we
must not bother doing it yeah
so we'll we'll take it from there we
will put it back to
all members i think if it just goes out
to all members
and we have to just make sure that
we keep it and because we do it properly
you know
this is sort of related to um what we're
talking about keeping people better
informed about what's happening i i
should have raised it i've missed the
opportunity under your action list
okay quite often it's noted in the
action list that the committee have been
out of reply
now these questions are minuted in your
minutes
but nobody knows what the reply was
unless you're a member of the committee
so could we actually make sure that
the responses are somehow included
so that everybody is aware
of how those
issues that have been raised by your
committee have been addressed yeah fine
we can do that
do you mean kind of adding the answers
to the watching this uh
somewhere to actually inform it i think
councillor lankford asked about the
fivedown road easter water play area i
have no clue what the response was so it
will be helpful to know
we can we could include a response i'm
sure we can we can include the results
really really hard surely the response
the response did come out to the whole
of this committee because it's only
yes
responses
[Music]
that just
you know
okay so can we sorry can we clarify what
we've got to do we're going to send this
out quarterly to councillors
yeah
we're going to send we're going to send
the qbr
each qbr
out to all councils
well that's all right
when it's ready to go out we'll send it
out send an email out to all councillors
with the qbr with the request for
questions yeah so everybody gets to have
a look at it
early before the meeting and that will
go out separately to the agenda we
usually go to that week
at least a week before so everybody will
get to see it and also
the second part of that is that we'll
add
the answers yeah to the action list
so that we can kind of keep it into the
circle and then
[Music]
thank you very much for that
we'll move on
we did felt on the other
[Music]
okay
let's move on let's move on
item number nine
peer review
okay
peer review
oh you're doing it don't you i
was i wasn't uh intended to do it but it
may be beneficial to some members who
might not know
um
the details of peer reviews because
that's not something we've done
in this administration you'd see from
the
uh
attached reports to the agenda in 2013
and 2017
benefits
what they are what they're about so
um any
local authorities uh councils whether
they're district councils unitary
councils county councils or like uh who
are members of the local government
association
are invited should they wish to
participate in the peer review program
uh what that essentially is is you get a
an external uh group of assessors
ordinarily um led by a chief executive
from an authority of an equivalent size
scope etc so you'll note our last peer
review
undertaken in 2017 the lead appearance
nigel lynn
district council
they're supported or the team then has
member gears
you'll see the last
year we've had a conservative member
here from
uh daventry and an independent member
here from north carolina so again
similar types of authorities
and kind of sits similarly in line with
the political maker of the council
so what they they tend to look at they
can either be specific themes or it can
be a little bit more wide-ranging so
specific themes could be around the
financial health capacity of an
authority or it could be a bit more
wider looking at how the council is
performing how
its strategic plan looks how its
strategic objectives are kind of panning
out so having a look back but also
looking forward um in terms of the plans
the council has in place
so you'll know from the eight-year
agenda and there's one undertaken in
2013
and you'll see some of the key things in
there were around uh financial planning
because obviously at that time
we were in the midst of austerity
it was also it also focused a little bit
on the
the way the council was evolving at that
point in terms of shared arrangements
with our neighboring authority and
questioning some of the capacity um
within those arrangements in terms of
the management structure here and the
ability to move things forward obviously
that was some time ago and all of those
and all of those things have moved
forward we're no longer sharing folks
with north dakota um in terms of senior
management
looking at the the 2000 the more the
more recent uh review which was
undertaken in 2017
um it's probably worth just having a
look at page 35
which outlines the key recommendations
from that review
um and you'll see review the strategic
goals and priorities for torrents in the
light of the
emerging joint local plant at that point
obviously we've got another emerging
joint global plan assessing the
council's appetite for risk produce
costed resource delivery plans for the
council's main project areas supporting
councils in reaffirming the privacy of
the strategic community leadership roles
in avoiding involvement in management
and operational detail
and creates more output outward-looking
and confident council supporting the
growth board and enhance the full-time
expertise and capacity to improve and
improve the perception of the planning
service
so obviously that was uh that was four
years ago um arguably i i would
i would suggest that most of those
recommendations either within your
current strategic plan because these
kind of reviews uh work through and work
through into subsequent
strategic plans should the council wish
to adopt them
obviously the council adopted its
strategic plan um late in 2020 which
kind of forms the basis for the the rest
of the boy's
discussions around the qbr
um
ordinarily we'd be kind of coming up for
another
review
um obviously with the strategic plan
being delayed and many things being
delayed because the pandemic that hasn't
happened
we
meet regularly the leader and i with our
local regional lga advisor
and we've had tentative discussions
around when would be a suitable time for
a future review
and given the
amount of resource um being currently
directed to toward your current
strategic plan and in particular leisure
um
grounds maintenance
how to housing delivery plan and so
forth it was probably felt the best time
would be after the next
election in 2023 when you'll be looking
back and setting another strategic uh
the strategic direction of the council
charlie we'll leave it there and
the committee for any discussion
right any questions
well just
noticing a theme that goes through both
but one of the things is lack of
investment opportunities to increase the
income stream in order to stabilize the
financial situation it doesn't seem to
me as though we've been terribly
energetic on that
a bit yeah there's key recommendations
here also the perception of planning i
mean amongst the general population
there is
a sort of fatalism about planning and
about development and
that's a serious problem
[Music]
you may recall that this committee
developed an income generation strategy
and
that has been delivered and delivered
lots of
different things and one of it was the
things around ethical investments which
we were talking about yesterday as well
as invested in property so we built the
council down lower building next door
obviously commissioned and built the car
park down westwards bowl to develop
additional income so i would suggest uh
the committee's done quite a
considerable bit of amount of work on
income generation
i don't
is not doing good at all well i'm just
telling you what the response is in the
community you know just despair
well i i i i i know that i know you're
an australian government
um you know what yeah we have to do it
with gold to be quite honest but
some years ago um i think it was at the
time of day green
i used to get
hellish amount of people complaining
about planning
and
i would say 95 of that
has gone now
and planning on doing extremely well
and i won't keep looking at ken james
because
it's going to make me laugh in a minute
um
but but they are doing exceptionally
well under the circumstances as well
you know we it's it's not been a good
time for them
you know they've all
they're all
overworked uh but they are doing
extremely well
and i will hear a bad word said against
them to be quite honest
i'm just reporting what they're here
sorry i think one of the answers lies in
the review of the local plan and
strength well this is what this is what
we do this is what we're doing now or
starting to do now
i mean because
we we yes we when we did build the the
one that we've got now
campbell can we
it was terrible for rural and this is
one of the reasons that we're doing it
to be quite honest
and i
teamwork so it needs to be clear if
you're talking about who's from outside
of the local plane that's different to
the work of the team and as
councilor watson pointed out the team
worked particularly hard uh the amount
of workers as we saw yesterday gone up
substantially over the last two years
with a number of
applications and
we've you know we've put additional
capacity into our team so we need to
make sure we separate those challenges
and
the amount of money that that was earned
through planning last time
will be even more this time
yeah that means more development
yeah well we have to do it
you know we can't we can't sit back and
say well we can't
we don't want we can't build outers
helps we'll get in trouble with central
government and then
you won't get like that because they'll
come and say well
you're having these just there
and that's how it works the big issue is
making sure people are involved
in this local plan review right from the
beginning the whole population you know
because
all around where i know people just
obviously weren't aware of but but if i
remember right
when we were doing the
the previous plan the one that we have
now
consultation things were sent out to
everybody
parish councils
you know i'm afraid for some reason
i mean that's why northern town council
i mean people obviously weren't aware
that that was the development side i
mean you may say it's their fault but i
tend to wear on the side of us making
people more informed really at least you
know intelligent people they just don't
seem to be aware of it
wow that's really to start i'm sure i'm
sure there's enough information out
there
so they could be aware of it
but then again then again we're getting
into a situation now where we're just
talking about planning this is not what
i'm just picking up one of these
recommendations yeah anyway simon yeah i
mean
i mean
people the communication that you're
talking about that the conduit of
communication has got to be the parent
counselors i mean they're the people who
get consulting
and if they're not communicating well
it's they that need kicking yeah the
difficulty surely
of the council at this level
communicating with everybody directly
when there's already an infrastructure
through the parish council now you know
either they represent and also inform
their local communities or they
but um the
so i don't think we need to beat
ourselves with the stick for their
failure in particular
uh
i always make a i made a point of
talking about it the other day with sean
harrington but it's almost unfortunate
that the local plan is sponsored by
planning because actually the local plan
is about everything other than planning
planning is a consequence of that
um planning policy but you know it's all
about how we want to live and etc which
is much wider than strict planning um
and people do see it as a planning
document but in fact it's something much
wider and
much more of a statement as to how the
community wants to live yeah
nick
uh yes
can i just go back to the income
generation which i thought this item was
about
yesterday a big investment went into the
west
but it's almost unseen
i think the figures on the tennis ball
must be very disappointing
when it is constructed in business you
create and then you advertise and you
get your response we don't advertise it
we're constrained
by the county council
and we have little signs
at the top of the road leading to it
when people are trying to get into the
main parking ground and they're leaving
west with hope because they don't
realize
that we have this
huge purpose-built parking rat the
county let us put up a little sign about
this thing
now what we have to do
and what are we going to be office
is to look around and find places where
they can enable good signage
i i give you an example on the corner of
this road is westwood hokar
in the corner of that car we have a
little county council sign this big
overflow campaign
we need to find the sites and advertise
it
we've created it
we're not selling school
and that's the type of thing i think
i think all
all investments have to be reviewed and
if they're not performing well enough
um we're going to find a way of making
them
thank you for letting
apologies steve you said this and it's
gone over my head
i'm just intrigued um who actually sets
the themes do they come out of a
strategic plan or is it an agreement
between the peer-reviewed people and the
council
of these
um probably a little bit of both
so
um what tends to happen and that's why i
said it it's not related but there's a
huge amount of french resource required
so
um once it's set up
um the people and once the team is
established they will contact us for a
whole range of information and john and
i have been involved before so looking
at our strategic and looking at all our
qbr's looking at all our financial plans
and probably probably be risk assessed
because if
[Music]
a difficult financial position for
example uh they may suggest shall we
look at these themes so it's a it's kind
of a bit of a negotiated
um structure to it
anymore steve are you wanting a
a response from us on your suggestion of
timing
no no okay i mean that's fine
i i kind of outlined the the reasons why
we haven't done one at this point and
why it's sensible to kind of leave it
for a period of time otherwise we'll
have to stop doing things like the
implementation of the leisure project
for example because it does take up an
extraordinary amount of
time
here
the reason why i raised it early wrong
was the fact that
the review just introduced um maybe well
over four years ago now
what i feel sometimes is this council is
this committee what we don't do is
actually bring something back and
actually look at it i know within this
as well there's an awful lot of things
that we discussed as a committee um
affordable housing is a classic
but nonetheless
what was interesting was at the
beginning because there's new members
steve had to explain what a clear review
was surely
if we're doing things we should be
bringing them back to the table
not to
disseminate but to actually know that
things move on and things are different
so therefore some of the challenges we
have in the theory now of 2017
are different from what we're facing at
this present time and perhaps the
conversation should come around that way
but
one of the things i'd look at all the
way through is that we still have
a consistent amount of of issues that
we had in 2013 2017
um
one of the things was staff capacity
how many times we actually hear
what i looked at last time we've got
homelessness we've got a budget there
and it's not being used so therefore our
ability to actually do the staff
capacity
the other thing is one that comes out in
2013-17
is understanding the roles between
councillors and the the executive i
think that's still something that gets
us
and the other thing as well it was
looking at the which i'm interested in
the economy when you look at the economy
in 2013 and 2017 we've still got the
same sort of issues you don't seem to be
moving on
and i think some of these things this
this wise suggestion that you actually
have appear with you come in so people
actually look at what's been discussed
in the past that identify some of the
issues
[Music]
um
the number of staff staff capacity is
obviously subject to budgetary
constraints as much as anything else and
that's something
members tasked me with looking at when i
was appointed last year and we've had
implemented a restructure and we've
increased staff capacity in the areas uh
where your strategic plan identified so
for example major projects and property
we've got
we've split that department in
two so we've now got a property manager
and a major projects manager which
equally then links into things around
economic regeneration because it frees
up that officer and his team to look at
projects rather than just looking at
day-to-day property issues
we've done the same in planning so
sean harrington's
now on our operational management team
and we've backfilled his post with
having smith to provide additional
capacity in that team so in terms of
staff capacity we have increased it
obviously you always need to be mindful
of recruiting loans loads of staff when
we have quite a precarious budget
position the last thing you want to do
is recruit loads of people on that
posture uh maybe lots of stuff redundant
that would certainly not
look good for the council in any uh
manual
on a matter of interest what's the
workload in setting up a peer review
presumably you have to
you have to nominate people to carry it
out and contact them
um i'm just interested right
now we we don't nominate the lga
suggests
the peer review team it'll be
[Music]
members and officers who have no
direct contact with
the council
because that wouldn't as we talked about
earlier marking your own homework isn't
the best method so uh they are contacted
us for the contact us with the suggested
team and we have an opportunity to
suggest whether or not they're
appropriate or not you know they'll give
us the details of them
their background skills or to ordinarily
because they
don't want to know all the councils they
can select from a
group of peers who are
part of that process across the country
so you agreed on the people and then
there's funding involved
does it have to be paid for in some way
why not absolutely
um i can't remember whether we paid for
it i don't think so obviously you pay
for it in terms of the the resource
commitment uh doing that as i said
it would take what it takes quite a lot
of officer time which is why i suggested
it's not the right time currently it's
supposed to be
next april
from next april sometime
it's not it's not a strict timetable
it's a
disgrace discretion when you do it you
don't have to have a peer review at all
not every council does obviously it's
recommended practice because it's good
for somebody external a group of
external assessors to have a look how
you're doing
kind of it's kind of like meant to be
like a critical friend rather than a
strict audit
um to make sure the council's going in
the right direction assuming you know
when you agree these people they go away
and write
do they research and write the reviews
so where's the officer involvement
during that period
where do they get the information from
right okay so yeah
right
any more
questions
okay
we'll move on then
all right
item 10 urgent decisions um i believe
we've got we've got two people answering
questions on this
design
okay
where do we start on this
yeah
[Music]
this period so set out in the report on
page 48 is the urgent decision process
so you'll see
there's a number of stages that have to
be followed
obviously i uh consider it uh first off
i'm happy that there is a need for a
decision uh consult with the leader and
the chair of their community and
resources and require both support and
signature in order to implement that
decision
um set out on pages 50
51
and 52
are the decisions the urgent decisions
that have been taken
uh since
during 2020 and 2021
i'm sure members will note
that the majority five of the six i
think
are decisions required because the the
government implemented changes as a
result of the pandemic and many of the
dates uh were needed before an upcoming
committee could be called some were
advised after the start of the the
process so i i'm also intending going
through
all of them individually members
had the papers
and the other one was in relation to a
response to
government's um consultation on some
planning changes and again
the timing of which was
impossible to achieve so
all of those decisions once they've gone
to the urgency process are
retrospectively reported to a community
resources committee
so at that point members have the
opportunity to ask
myself the leader or the trainer of the
committee any questions they
they should wish answered and chair
happy to answer any questions if there
are i don't know whether uh the leader
wants to add anything do you want to say
something ken yeah
you want to call beer and speak into the
money and watch
you're happy
what you have to bear in mind is that
it's been done mostly through cover and
very often we've got instructions on
friday
sometimes on a saturday sometimes and
expected to implement stuff early in the
week so
you know we've been in the situation we
weren't having full meetings we were
expecting to get the money out
particularly
the hard work that
has been done by officers in
implementing some of these you know when
um one of the first schemes we have
called
officers coming in
coming in weekends
it's not the way we'd like to do
exactly what kenneth said and we should
know that that moneys were going to
businesses that were really immediate
but up to three weeks in advance of our
neighboring involvement you know it was
to add credit and to the officer's
credit
yeah
and that has to be done first class
yeah
simon will you
as as the
member who i think probably led the
charge on asking for this um
this report um
i would first of all thank officers i
know it's extra time taking support
together
it is a useful snapshot especially
during a time where urgency procedures
because of physics had to be used quite
a lot for an unusual amount of time um
and i think as a matter of oversight it
is just useful to
have captured this and that the fact
that we have seen it in addition to cnr
i know cnr see each one but they're
actually acting on the the measure
that's brought before them we're just
we're looking more at the the process
and
having looked through all of the the six
occasions it's been used it's very clear
that the justification was clearly there
on each occasion and that we as a we as
a committee should
should whatever we do noted or or or
whatever but it's there on the record
that we have actually looked at it and
and tipped it off
is useful for
you know
future accountability if ever
yeah
all right
any more questions
you know you wanna say anything else ken
no no for
leave your sure
okay now we'll leave it there
um
we'll move on
listen
[Music]
david had the benefit of speaking most
last night so i i got away with it
uh yeah yes just uh a brief update then
on uh the position with the the
implementation of our leisure services
uh members will know we've uh we just
we're just about
to press the button on setting up active
toilet
[Music]
uh later this morning just to finalize
that
uh you will be aware we've appointed
judith gentry as a non-executive
director to add real commercial
expertise and experience to the the
shadow board as it currently stands
and we've appointed matthew reiter's are
head of leisure operations who will be
starting with us just after christmas
and he'll provide that kind of
operational expertise uh providing the
link between
uh the board finally the operation so
all of them all of that those things are
moving forward um the boards have
approved the design logo colors for
active storage uh i will be moving
forward procurement signage and things
like that
um
i think so
there's
we've still got a hell of a lot of
a lot of work to do particularly after
christmas so we're still engaging with
16 10 in terms of standard staff
transfer information that's required
under the the tutely process i won't go
in i can't go into the detail
around that in an open
but that's progressing quite well
um the the
project
over overall is still green in terms of
its kind of
rank risk respecting
as i said there's still quite a lot for
us to do as a board and as to do as a
council supported support in the board
so yes everything's moving forward happy
to take any particular questions um but
probably at the the next meeting we'll
be able to give a more detailed uh
update because we'll be kind of really
into the meat of the transfer
implementation i just got more questions
for you um judy
is she still involved with the burton
i don't i don't believe so but that's
that wouldn't be an issue
uh for work because it's a
separate entity anyway if that's natural
okay yeah can i just say you know i've
been involved
long long time about nearly 40 years
and we've gone through ups and downs um
what we're trying to do what we want to
do with the um what i've been doing
outside is steve knows when we go to
meetings we've challenged people a bit
where's college you know we keep hearing
about north dakota and west ham
at like with the grants management we
want to see vans over there doing a very
good job with tdc
and it will be the same with this we
want to see those buildings with torrid
signs on and people not just
there's
just being proud of what we are and you
know faces the challenges sometimes
um
i said to steve just the last week of
service we've gone heavily back into big
farming a bit silly um it's very tiring
it's very challenging i'm making code of
all of you you know from every officer
way through claire does the um
the collections for the raffles and that
because we've produced
if you look back over my time being at
this council we don't pat ourselves on
the back
do we no you know uh and
the times that it's been said about we
should put this out to the press
and and blow ourselves up you know this
is what we need to do in it
well one thing we're not doing i mean
north devon keeps on getting publicity
for their affordable housing commitment
but we're not publicizing authorities
doing
i don't think
but
i just can say one of the one of the
things obviously over the past couple of
weeks in terms of publicity we've had an
election running so that's kind of
restricted uh because we were due to
have uh some information in the example
of what torridge was doing but because
the because of purdue because the
election weren't able to
progress that but it would be done in
the libya but
yeah we need to do it a bit more often
nick yes i think after you we've
finished right yes we are
oh i say because i'm part of the council
like steve is
um
i think we're doing really well now the
new website
public information there easily got been
being picked up by the press there's
bits of news every day coming out of
torridge uh it's been lacking in the
past but it's not lacking now
and uh yeah the profile is kind of it's
going to work
great
simon last one last one related um
the
local authority trading company that is
about to
launch yeah um
can we confirm is the responsibility for
oversight excruciatingly internal or
excellence
it would be extra unless it's an
external company this would probably be
one of those areas that
some somewhat difficult and we are
trying to think about it it's an
external company
but obviously provided services
that the council did before and
obviously
maintenance contract is internal to the
council because we're in sourcing
[Music]
we'll have to decide if we have to
determine because we don't want both
internal and external um
maybe you have a joint or something like
that but we'll look into that a little
bit definitely now that's wrong but
who has it yes
that's that's the way i see it again to
be quite honest that's the way i see it
looking you know internal
so yeah okay
any more questions
[Music]
when we do the budget i think we should
be just left alone with doing that
everybody agree
well we're gonna the other thing might
have to come back just for a bit of an
update
yeah
yeah
say anything
um
can i just um
i see janet from there for the empty
home strategy
uh i was just trying to remember there
was some sort of report homelessness
strategy or homelessness report that she
thought was going to be done by
december was that but might not have
been but and is that coming to full
council or will that come to us
i think she's supposed to come back to
us
i think you'll probably be seeing our
forecast so i need to check so what
happens here i i
that's the one that's on there so that's
the empty home strategy is all part of
that same picture and they said that
because janet was explaining it
i believe that's what that's what it is
because as part of the discussion that's
when this opening was added so it may be
that we've added the wrong description
okay that's as my understanding was
when she came here that's when that item
was added to the agenda that's right
right okay thank you
[Music]
considered
a couple of months ago and we agreed we
developed these uh delivery plan and we
brought that back to full council
and joined the leader
certainly will be discussing where we
are with that in order to time it right
i suspect it'll probably be the end of
january um
where we are
right then